uh i want to go to something absolutely
fascinating you know
um in all of this discussion in the last
month about mike pence could have
mike pence should have mike pence had a
duty to overturn the 2020 presidential
election results and of course he didn't
have that ability and he certainly
didn't have the duty to do it
one of the things that is increasingly
being mentioned is well if mike pence
could effectively choose the winner
of an election then that means kamala
harris could do the same thing in 2024
kamala harris could decide who wins
understanding that it's not just she
says i award the presidency to whoever
by strategically choosing to reject the
ballots from certain states and send
them back for an alternative slate of
elections you guys understand it's a
little bit more nuanced than just the
vice president chooses well donald trump
former donald trump economic adviser
peter navarro appeared on msnbc and was
interviewed by ari melber and this is
really good because ari melbourne just
says to him well i mean if pence could
do it
then kamala harris could do it right
and uh peter navarro twists himself into
an incredible pretzel
to put a final note on this section yes
uh it would follow from your contention
that you think
vice president harris will ultimately
have the call over who should be
president regardless of the results in
the next
election see you you misconstrued the
whole green bay sweep plan it's not for
the vice president to determine who wins
okay the only thing that prince had the
authority to do
is go back to the states and let the
states look at the votes it's the states
in our constitution who have the right
to decide who won an election but you're
not asking but which states were they
that he had the right to do that with
and on what basis was he going to say
i'm sending this back to the states
because remember all the legal
challenges that were filed at the state
levels were found to be without merit
bring the
it on harris questions
you peter to ask for a second yeah it
seems like it makes you but it seems
like it's making you stretch when we
just change the name from pence to
harris are you no no no no no holding
the contention let me finish the
question you'll get your response peter
let me finish the
right so let's say that
under your contention vice president
harris could take any states that her
side lost and selectively send those
back that's your current contention
if if
any any vice president
under the electoral account act of 1887
we'll get to that act by the way if
there are objections that are raised
about estates electors the
provision is that you have two hours of
that now the problem with this if there
are objections raised
they raised objections without merit
only in certain states so of course if
the shoe were on the other foot
and kamala harris said well you know
what we have objections that have been
raised in florida and ohio and i'm going
to send them back people like peter
navarro would be out there saying but
those objections aren't legitimate and
that's the issue because he says well if
objections have been raised
the vice president can say we're sending
it back and i don't know in arizona
their plan was to just say we're going
to send you republican electors
the question is who determines the
legitimacy of those objections and none
of the objections raised by these
trumpists in arizona or michigan or
wherever were found to have any merit
now i want to mention one other piece
he says the electoral count act of 1887.
the electoral account act of 1887 was
put in place because nine years prior
there was a disputed election and it
took nine years and they put together
this act in 1887.
it puts the onus of solving disputes on
the states it doesn't say that if there
is a state dispute the vp can say we're
sending arizona back
send us the republican electors that was
their plan the electoral count act is
very narrow and these trumpets don't
care now you go to the rallies and they
repeat it electoral count act of 1887
the electoral count act of 1887 says
if there is a dispute like for example
in arizona
the vice president could say we're going
to send this back
to resolve the dispute in the state
but the disputes that the trump people
put together in places like arizona were
found to be without merit you don't get
to say well there is a dispute so we're
going to ignore the nine or however
seven electoral votes for biden from
arizona and instead we'll accept seven
electoral votes for trump that's not how
it works and
the entire framing of what that
electoral count act did
is being completely bastardized by these
people you probably know that so
not surprising when confronted with well
if pence could get to pick doesn't
kamala get to pick he says well it
depends on whether there are disputes
right but who decides if the dispute is
legitimate well they do
apparently they do and mike pence was
supposed to decide that we'll have this
clip on our instagram if you've just
been listening today find us on
instagram at david pakman show